the mid-range segment is very
competitive says connoisseur Emmanuelle
Schaefer especially the station wagons
many renowned German manufacturers offer
such a vehicle like the Audi a4 BMW
3-series opals insignia the Ford Mondeo
and so forth that makes it tough for
foreign brands like the Toyota Avensis
last year sales of the Avensis didn't
even reach 4,000 in Germany compare that
with VW which can sell that many cars in
two weeks
so the question is whether the Toyota
Avensis is rightly avoided or an insider
tip is fine one geheime tip a car's
design is a matter of taste and beauty
is in the eye of the beholder
the Toyota Avensis Turing sports offers
a choice of two gasoline and two diesel
engines we're testing the most powerful
diesel
with two litres displacement and 105
kilowatts of power this engine
accelerates the stationwagon to 109
point eight seconds top speed is 200
kilometers an hour
he moto venema venzas Amano says Toyota
developed the Avensis engines in
collaboration with BMW but Toyota
doesn't offer an engine with more than
110 kilowatts or 150 horsepower that's
where other cars in the segment like
most are just starting out a 130
kilowatt engine used to be offered for
the Avensis but Toyota retired it it was
purchased so rarely that it wasn't worth
producing that's this involved it's
Google in touch so the Avensis isn't
striving for sportiness so much as for a
thrift the curves on the front make the
Japanese car seem a bit chubby cheeked
but the roofline descending to the rear
is almost elegant storage space in the
events the station wagons trunk is
between 543 and 1609 liters in
comparison the Passat trunk holds up to
1780 liters Amano has mixed feelings
about the interior some parts are good
others a bit dismal dirty with the
plastic on the door handle it has all
the charm of a utility vehicle he says
but he finds the instrument cluster very
attractive simple but nice just like the
center console there the sat-nav and
various switches are all simple but nice
the thing in contrast the controls from
the steering wheel seem thrown together
what bothers Emanuele the most is the
grey on the gearshift it's not found
anywhere else in the car down here
there's great - but it's not and it's
found nowhere else in the car either
it's ghastly and doesn't fit with the
rest of the car amano well the noise
level inside the Avensis seems a little
louder than in those competitors it's
not terribly loud but it could
definitely be quieter especially when
you accelerate the
on 2,000 rpm you clearly notice it but
the engine needs those revs to really
get any power both them what's all my
things off to one's o'clock
nothing's lacking in the Avensis when it
comes to safety a pre-collision system
Lane Departure alert automatic high-beam
assistant and many other systems
simplify and protect the drivers and
passengers lives road sign assist warns
the driver when he exceeds the speed
limit it's all subsumed under the title
safety sense and that standard equipment
and all equipment lines after spending a
day in the Avensis Amano says he
understands why it sells so poorly
the design is polarizing not everyone
likes it apparently most people don't
like it the entry-level price a bit
above 24,000 euros in Germany is lower
than most other cars in the segment but
for just 1600 euros more you get an Opel
Insignia and for another 2,000 you
arrive at the VW Passat and both of them
have a much better design and more
storage space making them more practical
for everyday use microphone volume on
the intense question practice truck for
the night attack
[Music]